let's get some analysis now from Gary B
Smith president of Kadena Group and a
Fox News contributor
Gary listen it's Jerome Powell's first
day as Fed chair not exactly the best
day to come in but there is this
interesting dynamic in the market where
the economy may be doing well
fundamentally but just the threat of
interest rates going up really spook
some folks yeah exactly Brad look I
think that that the focus on inflation
and the Fed is a little overdone there's
a lot of people in the market that have
never really lived through high
inflation like there was in the 70s if
people look at inflation right now at
the end of 2017 inflation still only 2%
we live in a far different kind of
economy than we did even 5 10 years ago
because of companies like Amazon out
there because of you know it's so much
that you can get from China it's very
difficult across the board to find a
company or a retailer or a grocer that
can really actively raise prices and
that's the key to inflation that's why
look I'm not not unworried if you will
but I'm not I think this was kind of
abnormal although abrupt pullback that
we had right so is this a correction per
se I mean we got to a point we were down
1600 today you know came back towards
the end of the day but as you're looking
at where the the fundamentals of this
economy are you know what should the
average investor be thinking I think the
average investor to be saying now if I
have some money to deploy now might be a
good opportunity I'm not saying buy all
tomorrow morning because after a
volatile day a lot can happen we could
open way down but the fact is most
people as Deirdre pointed out are flat
for even 2018 we've been up about 260
percent since I think 2008 we're up even
a 55% I think since the bottom in 2000
in late 2015
this I think is normal profit-taking we
went straight up but unlike the other
sell-offs breath that we had in in 98 in
2000 that we had under pinnings like the
housing crash financials the
underpinnings here are very good as you
point out as the president pointed out
Gary B as always thank you very much
thank you Bret